This morning
my husband ran out of the moisturizer that he usually uses
and he didn't love it enough to repurchase,
so he just decided to make his own.
He combined some beef tallow and beeswax in a metal bowl
and let that melt over some boiling water.
Once everything was melted down,
he turned off the heat before he mixed some squalene and ojoba oil,
which he poured back into the melted beeswax and beef tallow
before giving that a good stir,
taking that off the heat and adding the last three things,
which was some vitamin E oil,
hyaluronic acid, and glycerin.
He made sure to give it a mix after adding each ingredient
and at the end just mixed it until it was all combined.
Once combined, he transferred it over to a little glass jar.
He made sure to fill all the way to the top
before scraping off any extra popped on the lid
and transferred it over to the fridge to set.
Later that night when we got out the shower, we decided to test it.
I struggle with eczema and really dry skin,
so he didn't add any essential oils so it would also work for me.
We loved it.